o bom é só uma mãe tira todos os chamo
chaves e juntamente precisas em casa
aqui uma pessoa morre a noite ronaldinho
a gente resolveu formar se tem um
futebol que a gente vai rolar um
pouquinho em pouquinho da história do
curso vocês vai contar a história de
praia na década de 30 e resolver outros
percorreram princípio não é admissível
ou não à procura de autoafirmação
simplesmente nessa busca
ele resolve pactuar com alta
trocando a sua alma
ela foi algo que surpreendesse as
pessoas que ouvem se tocar e e e com os
acordes e teve em conta a história não
só na hora do impacto a defesa mas a
história de todos os livros sagrados a
recebimentos de um ex-agente escravidão
das faturas
essa música é obra de uso é só você com
texto em baixo
a gente também vai começar o cabelo
é o homem
gal costa
o marcelo e sim
o algodão
o vôo o gol
cassel
ae
cantava
eu não sei
o
quero sair do papel
ae
o pt fará
elton
ae
a wii
o real siga baú
então o pessoal deve estar se
perguntando nec congresso está
acontecendo naquele preciso instrumentos
que é isso né não podemos lidar muito
bem com baixo ou menos tambor e no chão
mas kashef qual é o homem foi ao poder
eles são chamados de se ver box esses
instrumentos foram populares na época
nos estados unidos nessa área é onde o
pessoal não tinha matéria prima muito
menos dinheiro para adquirir um
instrumento musical os índios também da
musical então as nossas enormes
utilizando que estão afinados até o fim
do show ele traz músicas da banda
elas vão vê-los com vários objetos no
cotidiano
o velho na função há duas maneiras de
reaproveitar de bateria que estavam com
os pés em janelas no bairro em cada
janela e caixa de charutos que é o nosso
amigo andré bay está tocando ainda hoje
eu puxar o que eu só consegui sacar elas
é bastante utilizado naquela época
também tinha bastante disponível pessoal
e elas eram feitas com um material de
qualidade é uma maneira de qualidade
então produziu tinha uma característica
acústica com com uma caixinha de um nome
então só é seguro bops de dentro e siga
cop 10 que a gente tentou reproduzir as
músicas botas
hum
o raio resume ele
o bom velhinho opel cena maio
ai ai ai
ae
duda
ronaldo prometeu bola é uma mãe
ae
a prosa
em nossas pesquisas como o dinheiro cruz
nossa preparação pro e dez vezes a gente
repensar um pouco
a banda que ele está fazendo porque
esses instrumentos que a gente repensar
como transmitir a nossa mensagem essas
histórias do lux como passar isso aqui
pra vocês hoje uma maneira honesta e
sincera e nós nos deparamos com essas
perguntas seria pra repente pra passar
um mero faça você mesmo anunciar esses
senhores ao invés disso o blues as suas
histórias
essa pesquisa apresentação aqui no tb ex
nos trouxe um seja você mesmo
independente da sua classe social da sua
cor e comprimento de cabelo
nós com 12 mortes
optamos por abrir mão de instrumentos
super afinar weiss de marcas famosas
conseguem consequentemente caríssimas
pra sentir na pele uma fagulha da vida
chamada a todos muito obrigado essa
nossa mensagem para você corre
ela conta um pouquinho ela volta à
trajetória a história de robert johnson
que é o carro igual a eles nossa
apresentação
o cara os precursores do agora obrigado
o caso algum tempo avaí é a morte de
alguns conhecidos social do rio paraná
machava ia ver na rua oito de cada dez
autocarros o gol
você tem que ver o teu joão jorge na rua
final acaba lhe ofereceu
pode ser afinal quem tem carro
é um ardil e 19 carros
o velho me se é ficou difícil ouvir a
palavra do senhor
o pecado contigo
o corte ao deus só pelas ruas do bairro
o fogo tem mais é que se contentar
incluiu esse tipo de rocha lançada no
reino do haiti pode dizer não liga pra
mais um beijo em geral minha ganso
ae
a 0 e disse confiar no senhor
vou tentar continuar a confiar neles
alvirrubros mundial uigur barrou tem
mais é que se contentar a quem não viu
isso implique será obrigado a rua assim
quase i liga o rádio e andré na barriga
guarde o frio é da minha área de que ele
terá na ocasão
o google